[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
to lose someone so young and so vital is
a tragedy in and of itself but to have
it happen in this way with the senseless
act of violence it's unimaginable days
after she was abducted a memphis heiress
and mother is found murdered and the
disappearance of kylie rodney she's not
in the driver's seat
it looks suspicious to me dive team
video shows the moments rescue teams
found the 16 year old's body plus this
is going to turn into a
circus
of media outlets publishing salacious
material that has absolutely nothing to
do
with guilt or innocence in this case
attorneys for only fans model courtney
cleney argue to keep evidence out of the
public's eye as she faces murder charges
for the april stabbing death of her
boyfriend
and later this brings the count of this
tragedy to 11 deceased persons
19 injured
and 13 crime scenes
a string of deadly stabbing attacks
across canada's saskatchewan province
what we know about the suspects involved
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everybody to long crime daily
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
the body of a memphis heiress teacher
and mother of two was recovered just
days after she was abducted while out
for a run investigators say 34 year old
eliza fletcher was last seen alive on
friday september 2nd just after four
o'clock in the morning officials say she
was out for a run when she was forced
into a black suv and taken away
officials used surveillance video to
track down the driver of the vehicle
38-year-old cleotha abstinent he was
arrested on saturday and charged in
connection to fletcher's disappearance
and on monday memphis area investigators
discovered a body near where absent was
seen cleaning out his vehicle on tuesday
investigators confirmed the body
belonged to fletcher right now a cause
of death has not been made public at a
press conference on tuesday officials
announced absent would face additional
charges including first degree murder
and especially aggravated kidnapping
while the outcome
of this investigation is not what we
hoped for
we are nonetheless pleased to remove
this dangerous predator off the streets
of memphis the defendant was arraigned
this morning
on charges of kidnapping and tampering
with evidence he'll be arraigned
tomorrow morning on new
charges that we now have to bring
of
first degree murder premeditated murder
murder in the course of perpetration of
a kidnapping
any kind of violence of course is uh
unacceptable but repeat violent
offenders particularly deserve a strong
response and that's what they'll get
from this district attorney's office
joining us today is co-host terry austin
and civil rights attorney joe richardson
it's good to see you both joe you heard
them talk about a repeat offender we
know that abstinent was previously
convicted of a kidnapping and he served
prison time until his release in 2018.
so should that have served as a warning
of what was to come here
well i think the word should assumes
that there's something that they could
have done to prevent this from happening
now if he had the right to be on the
street after he finished his time etc uh
i don't know that you can watch every
criminal that's been released is it a
surprise absolutely not and it looks
like
the dna there seems to be a dna
connection um etc there's apparently
some some some eyewitness uh testimony
that will probably come in in terms of
his location and so the dots connect
it's a terrible terrible tragedy uh but
uh we perhaps could have seen it coming
but could we as a society keep this
necessarily from happening if the person
had served his time so that sounds like
something that uh is uh more of a
beginning of the story about the release
of certain criminals uh you know extent
of uh prison time and some of those
types of things so it's not a surprise
but it's certainly a tragedy well what
we can say is terry the authorities they
wasted no time finding the suspect what
resources did they use and is that going
to be able to be introduced as evidence
at trial
well they had a plethora of resources
here and i think that's why they were
able to catch the suspects so quickly
first of all as we just talked about
there was surveillance video at the
abduction site and also at the theater
that he attended the day before and
there was a phone found in the street
there were a pair of sandals there were
dna evidence and the vehicle itself was
found at the home where he was
apparently staying and the same license
plate the same damage on the vehicle so
i think all of that evidence is going to
be admissible as long as you can you
know show a foundation and a chain of
custody
it's just a remarkably sad and to what
was a chilling story about this woman's
disappearance we're going to continue to
follow it here on the network
switching now to the pike county
massacre as opening statements are
delayed as george wagner iv stands trial
on multiple counts of murder opening
statements were scheduled for monday but
were pushed due to the illness of a
person involved with the trial george
wagner iv faces eight counts of
aggravated murder in connection to the
2016 deaths of the rodent and gilly
families prosecutors say that angela
wagner george billy wagner iii edward
jake wagner and george wagner iv killed
eight people in an effort to obtain sole
custody of jake's daughter
jake and angela already both confessed
to planning the murders and are expected
to testify against george wagner iv the
defendant maintains though he didn't
shoot anyone but faces the death penalty
if convicted opening statements are now
slated to be presented on monday
september 12th
and over in florida jurors have a weak
break from the parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial back in 2018 and
then 19 year old gunman opened fire at
marjory stoneman douglas high school 17
people were killed and 17 more were
injured in october of last year the
gunman pleaded guilty to all charges and
now a jury will decide whether he
receives life in prison or the death
penalty last week assistant public
defender melissa mcneill said she
planned to file a motion to prohibit the
state from seeking the death penalty and
complained that judge elizabeth sure
didn't rule on prejudicial evidence
judge shurer scheduled a hearing for
tuesday afternoon that was later
canceled jurors are due back in court
monday september 12th
still ahead on long crime daily we head
to florida for the evidentiary hearing
of an only fans model accused of a
murder but first the disappearance of
sixteen-year-old kylie ryden rodney
while why the dive team responsible for
finding her body says her death seems
suspicious
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody dramatic video
shows the moments a volunteer dive team
discovered the vehicle and body of
missing 16 year old kylie rodney rodney
was reported missing in early august
when she was last seen at a party near
lake tahoe she texted her mother that
she would soon return home but never
arrived her 2013 honda crv was also
missing weeks later the oregon-based
dive team adventures with purpose
announced it found rodney's body in the
overturned suv california officials
later confirmed the remains in vehicle
belonged to rodney so far cause of death
hasn't been released and the nevada
county sheriff's office says the
investigation is still ongoing meanwhile
adventures with purpose released a
youtube video titled quote how we found
kylie rodney murder or accident the
video shows the moments rodney's body
was discovered underwater and the
unexpected location of her
remains i see the vehicle and the
license plate we have just found kylie's
vehicle over
the vehicle is upside down
i repeat it is upside down i'm at the
rear of the vehicle now
i'm just confirmed
the passenger window is broken out
it appears
rear
driver's side window
is halfway
down she's not in the driver's seat
it looks suspicious to me
yeah so terry rodney's body was found in
the backseat of the vehicle do you think
that's enough evidence to turn an
apparent accident into a possible crime
here i do jessie it is very odd listen
when you have a motor vehicle accident
the first thing you think is that it's
an accident she was only 16 years old so
maybe she was inexperienced but here you
have her in the back seat of that car
the windows down or broken and there was
a roadside assistant his name was nick
he said he got a call from the two
people so apparently there was another
person in the car at least according to
this roadside person and they thought
that they had trouble with the battery
and the roadside assistant said he
thought it had something to do with the
stick shift but he basically said they
both sounded uneasy i think that's
enough for the authorities to take this
from the category of an accident and to
start looking at it as though there
might have been some foul play involved
joe we know the authorities weren't able
to locate the car in the body for nearly
two weeks but this volunteer group found
both of them right away you have to ask
is this a claim for negligence in a way
well you have to be able to say that
action or inaction by the police or
whoever was searching for her the
authorities as it were actually caused
her damage and i think that that's very
very cause damage unless you're talking
about the difference between her living
and dying which we're pretty sure we're
not talking about uh the police look bad
because these other folks went and found
her very quickly but there's no breach
of a duty that caused damage here and so
therefore you certainly have some hurt
feelings and some people that certainly
feel a certain type of way about them
not being found particularly when the
other group volunteer group found them
very quickly but it's not going to rise
to the level of negligence as it
pertains to the authorities that we're
searching for it's remarkable work that
they do it's just i wish they didn't
discover what they ultimately discovered
moving over to arizona days ahead of the
release of an in-depth netflix
docu-series on the so-called doomsday
cult duo laurie that laurie valodebel's
only surviving son is arrested for
alleged sex crimes
colby ryan faces two counts of domestic
violence sexual assault over an incident
with his estranged wife last week she
says after the two got together last
wednesday and were watching tv ryan
pressured her pressured her into having
sexual intercourse she says after she
told him to stop he kept sexually
assaulting her ryan's estranged wife
contacted police two days later to
report the incident and ryan admitted to
the rape and sexual assault he's
currently being held on a ten thousand
dollar bond ryan is the son of lori valo
dabil of the doomsday cult duo she and
her hus current husband chad dabel are
awaiting trial for murder charges for
allegedly killing ryan's sister tyler
ryan and laurie's other son jj ryan is
known for being a voice on behalf of the
children after they were killed and is
heavily featured in the upcoming
docu-series on netflix sins of our
mother the couple are also accused of
killing chad's former wife tammy the day
bells are set to go to trial together in
january
coming up on long crime daily one of two
suspects is found dead just days after a
series of deadly stabbings in canada
plus the defense for only fans model
courtney cleney wants to limit what
evidence is made public to the media
[Music]
welcome back only fans model courtney
cleney appears back in court tuesday
morning almost a month after the
instagram influencer was arrested for
the april stabbing death of her
boyfriend cryptocurrency traitor
christian obamacelli clenny has already
pleaded not guilty to second-degree
murder accused of stabbing obama with a
kitchen knife in their luxury florida
apartment on april 3rd she was initially
questioned over the incident but
released while officials investigated
and after clenny claimed that she threw
the knife at obamacelli stabbing him in
self-defense prosecutors say forensic
evidence though didn't support her
claims and that the medical examiner
determined he was stabbed at close range
prosecutors say clenny was the aggressor
in the relationship which was reportedly
regularly abusive clinty was arrested in
hawaii august 10 and then extradited to
florida in tuesday's hearing cleny's
attorneys argued for a protective order
in the case and the defense is seeking
to limit what evidence is made public
and accuses the media of chasing clicks
their numbers saying that oh we're not
affecting anything here we want access
freedom of the press to get all this
discovery which will contain salacious
materials
they want it all
to bump up the click the click to click
kaching which is the money the revenue
that they're driving through the clicks
to their site that's the motivation here
for the herald to intervene that
when we're countering the weight and the
influence that this will have on ms
clinton's trial down the road
her right to a fair and impartial jury
which i submit to the court by the state
already releasing that video has already
elongated the jury selection process by
days i washed my hands this morning
they're not unclean
they're clean
they've been clean
to
vigorously defend my client i'm not
going to stand back and let her be a
punching bag in the media something
needs to be put in place judge to
guarantee my clients right but also
the orderly administration of justice in
this courtroom
well the judge ultimately denied the
motion for the protective order as of
now clenny is set to face a jury trial
december 19th so joe you know the judge
denied the defense motion making some
strong arguments there from the defense
i mean did she make the right decision
you know it's a bit premature to say we
want to unring the bell and the fact
that this person has two million
instagram followers we don't want people
to watch everything that's going on and
everything that's out there about her
you effectively are unringing the bell
and so the judge is probably deciding to
be a little bit more pragmatic go down
the road and deal with specific things
as they come up for now i would argue
that it's probably the right decision
because just because something is uh
embarrassing does not necessarily mean
that it's prejudicial to the point that
it should not be used of course all of
that is going to be revisited as they
get more specific about specific things
that could be coming into evidence and
what they'll do with it but for now it's
probably the right decision and among
other things she's just you know gonna
be a victim of her personality her
personality her popularity and this
circumstance and it's not the judge's
responsibility to undo that well terry
just stepping back what was the
defendant's basis for wanting this
protective order
well you know i do agree with joe i
think the judge made the right decision
but the defense was trying to argue that
it should halt all discovery that
keeping everything out of the media was
the right way to go he talked about this
video of them in the elevator where you
see her fighting off you know the victim
who ultimately died and the argument was
a constitutional argument saying that
they have a right to a fair trial under
the sixth amendment and also under the
florida constitution and apparently some
of the evidence is going to be
inflammatory because there is sexually
explicit videos and and you know
photographs so i think the defense is
just really over broad and uh i think it
should wait until it comes in like joe
said well i think everybody can agree a
lot of eyeballs on this case a lot of
people following it we'll see if that's
currently the order or something will
change we move over now to a years-long
lawsuit fight that may be over for a
california man who sued over the cover
art of rock band nirvana's 31 year old
album never mind after a federal court
dismissed the case the lawsuit alleged
that the naked baby on the cover of the
1991 album constituted child pornography
now the child in the photograph now 31
year old spencer eldon sued the band
over alleged commercial child sexual
exploitation his attorneys claimed in
the original complaint filed last year
that eldon has suffered lifelong damages
as a result of his involvement in the
heavily viewed cover artwork that
complaint was dismissed but eldon filed
a second one claiming loss of income
earning capacity past and future wages
and loss of enjoyment of life a judge
ruled that elden filed the complaint
after the 10-year statute of limitations
had expired but eldon says he plans to
appeal that decision
when we come back a canadian man is
found dead after investigators say he
took part in a deadly stabbing spree
what we know so far about suspects and
brothers miles and damien sanderson and
their murderous rampage
[Music]
welcome back a weekend mass stabbing
leads to a manhunt in the canadian
province of saskatchewan officials say
brothers miles and damien sanderson are
responsible for the stabbing deaths of
10 people and injuring at least 18
others in what appears to have been a
partially random attack on sunday
morning the stabbings happened across 13
different locations where at least 18
people were treated at local hospitals
officials say some of the victims may
have been targeted by the suspects while
others were attacked at random the
identities of those who have been killed
have not been released but investigators
say none of them were infants or
children on monday authorities announced
that one of the suspects damien was
found dead with injuries that aren't
believed to have been self-inflicted
they say that his brother miles is
wanted and should be considered
dangerous
it was confirmed by saskatchewan rcmp
forensic investigation section that the
deceased is damien sanderson
his body was located outdoors in a
heavily grassed area in proximity to a
house that was being examined
we can confirm he has visible injuries
these injuries are not believed to be
self-inflicted miles sanderson
damien's brother may have sustained
injuries
this has not been confirmed
but we do want the public to know this
because there is a possibility he may
seek medical attention
miles has a lengthy criminal record
involving both persons and property
crimes
miles is facing three counts of
first-degree murder and is wanted
this brings the count of this tragedy to
11 deceased persons
19 injured
and 13 crime scenes
my gosh joe clearly we don't have all
the information yet but what do you make
of the statement that the brother who
was found dead he that he didn't die
from self-inflicted injuries
you've got
10 or 11 people dead you've got one
brother gone you've got another brother
still missing and no report of an
encounter with someone that says oh i
ran across them they tried to stab me i
tried to stab them i ran away so
it would seem to me it would suggest to
me that miles may have gotten into it
with his brother and maybe something
happened that way if things aren't
self-inflicted um but uh you know you
don't know until you know uh but it
would seem that maybe there was a
falling out between them or something
like that or this was part of miles's
plan um not exactly like their thinking
straight where we can kind of figure it
all out and have it make sense and be
logical but it would seem to me that
miles certainly knows what happened and
maybe involved with it
you know terry we talked so much about
gun reform so i have to ask 10 people
killed 18 others injured 13 different
locations how do we prevent something
like this from happening where the
weapons are knives you know you really
have to scratch your head on this one we
always talk about gun control but
obviously if this kind of mass killing
can be done with knives that anyone can
access at any time there are no
restrictions no background checks for
not you can just go in a store and buy
them so you have to really think about
prevention in another way so it looks to
me clearly as though there might have
been some mental health issues here you
have to look at the motive behind it
perhaps we can look at the source and
not just the result of this because in
this instance the knives were the really
lethal weapon and we've got to do
something about the person who's holding
the knife i think that's really well
said terry and on that note terry joe
thank you so much everyone out there
thanks for joining us here on long crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
assess justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you